[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell join this hour by the
incredible Jade warshaw there will never
be another one it's the only one she's
that unique and special and we are happy
to take your calls today about life
money and everything in between the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
George I feel the same way about you wow
thank you that means you always come up
with fun adjectives I I don't have it
today the parsimonious George camel
we've been hanging out with Ken Coleman
too long we're coming up with 10 words
well Jade as we get the phones going I
uploaded this video today on my YouTube
channel uh it was called why most people
will never be millionaires and I broke
down the four mistakes people make when
it comes to Building Wealth and
investing I love that and I've never
seen a more aggressive controversial
comment section I mean I'm sure the
people were feeling attacked George
let's be honest I was I just defined
what a millionaire is and I about
exploded the Internet by accident tell
can you tell us more like even I'm like
tell me more she's so intrigued you have
to subscribe to my YouTube channel well
here's the thing as as I opened the
video I said let's just be clear what a
millionaire is because some of y'all are
confused out there yes clear it up a
millionaire is not someone with a
million dollar salary right A
Millionaire is someone with a net worth
of one million or more right your assets
minus liabilities yes equals net worth
hey well for the people who are like hey
I'm a first time listener I'm just
getting this money thing explain assets
versus liabilities yes so assets are
things that you own like your house your
car your bank account your retirement
accounts all of those count as assets
that's right your liabilities are your
debts that's right so it's that's all of
the debts what you own minus what you
owe equals your net worth and I cannot
tell you how many people said well I
don't think he should count his house as
part of his net worth because that's not
an income producing asset and they're
trying to get all smart with me Jade and
I I don't have the heart or the energy I
think I'm getting too old and
curmudgeonly to have to fight back in
the comment section you want to know
what they're just dead wrong and it's
their American right yeah it's their
right to be wrong that's right George
well why wouldn't they want you to be
right I don't understand why the
argument I like Solutions where more
people get to get involved on the action
you lost everyone you said I like
Solutions people like drama and they
like problems and they want to wallow
and complain and tell you all the
reasons why they can't George you're
right now and I am for it I'm for this
it's going to be a hot show yeah this is
my this is my favorite you know what
Jade I'm done with cynicism because I
was that guy I was the troll in the
comments section going it'll never be me
and I don't want anyone else to have it
either and now I'm just going like I
know too much I feel cynical I know what
hope can do for people yeah and I want
to give you guys a taste of that if you
want to call on the show let's talk
about it let's do it George I I love
that and by the way if you haven't
checked out George's YouTube channel you
really should I feel like I feel like
this is the George everybody needs to
see this is all facets of George Snappy
smart George is one of the smartest
people I know
um so kind yeah the only reason I'm not
saying you're the smartest is because I
don't want to insult some people who
might be listening right now Dave Ramsey
mainly mainly Dave Ramsey no I
appreciate that uh five five dollars to
venmo uh on Jade goes a long way it
turns out so thank you for that you're
welcome let's get to the phones Megan
joins us in Atlanta up first Megan
welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
I love you all so much I'm looking for
your wisdom today sure how can we help
so I am um finalizing my divorce um
first of all thank you so much for all
of the videos on financial abuse and
financial infidelity from previous
callers that really helps to validate my
situation and know that I'm making the
best choice I'm so sorry Megan well yeah
thank you thank you so much
um but I'm at a point where I want to be
the wisest possible with how I pay out
my ex so I did decide to keep the house
and we already went through mediation
and negotiated that
um and I need to pay him out 185 000 I
have a few different options
um I have a spreadsheet in front of me
so I'm just trying to figure out the
wisest Choice sure
um
so what to know about our current
mortgage we only have 17 years left on
it and we have a two percent interest
rate which is just killing me to get rid
of
um and
um we owe about 190. so that's why I'm a
little hesitant to just you know go and
do a Cash out refinance
um that being said to cash that
refinance
um changing it to a 30 year loan taking
out that 185 is option number one with
the current mortgage interest rates
obviously that that option is is
heartbreaking
let me know if you have questions
because I'm kind of running through
everything really quickly sure yeah
what's up so that's option number one is
cash out refi option number two okay
option number two would be to get a home
at home equity line of credit for that
185 I currently have zero debts zero
student loans your credit card zero car
notes anything like that um so I could
get a pretty good interest rate on that
I've already talked to the bank
but I have a hesitancy about taking out
another loan
um
and it might just be in my head from you
know not wanting to take out loans and
then my third option is I think the most
controversial which I've been going back
and forth on quite a bit I'm running a
lot of numbers which would be
withdrawing 200k out of my 401k
um and then yes and then
um essentially taking
um just like working really hard to get
the tax penalties paid by tax time and
then throwing um just a ton in my 401k
after I'm done I'm lucky enough that my
employer does a 10 match and so I feel
like I could recoup that you're going to
spend your whole life trying to get back
to where you were on that 401k I don't
want that for you and this is why this
is why I want I want your wisdom so
um yeah you're between Iraq a hard place
and a really dumb Place yeah so we want
to help you get maybe give you a fourth
option hey let me ask you
um so you're wanting to keep can I ask
more questions about why you want to
keep this house and not do a fresh start
is it kids is it can you give me more
information on that
yeah good question so it's kids it's
school district and it's also with the
housing market right now um I mean if I
were to take that 180 plus our Equity
um it would be impossible for me to get
a house anywhere near what I currently
have
um for when I'm paying for it so I mean
it seems like a very wise choice it's
worth almost eight
um and so yeah it felt like the better
long-term financial plan but I mean feel
free to poke holes in it well I know I
don't like option two and three those
are just absolutely the HELOC and the
401K is definitely not it
um in my book yeah option one is your
best option so far but I'm with Jade on
wondering can can we actually afford
this house if this is where we're at if
these are the options I would love for
you to do a cash out refi and stick to a
15-year obviously that's going to be
tough with just your single income
correct
um I can do it so I make 150 000 like I
said I have literally zero debt besides
um this mortgage note so I can do it
I've not only been pre-approved like
I've done all the numbers oh good
something about lose something about
losing that two percent interest rate
though I know but I'm going to tell you
right now that is your best bet and if
the rates go down you can refinance
later on but I'm not going to argue over
two percent versus six percent I'm gonna
do this because it's the right thing to
do and it's the least harmful to your
financial future thanks for the call
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
there
watch and guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell Ramsey personality
joined by my colleague Jane warshaw
there we go here we go AAA
825-5225 you jump in if you need some
confirmation affirmation inspiration
motivation from Jade she's that's her
specialty well you're preaching over
there she pumps me up every day the best
all right let's get to uh well let's get
to our question of the day first shade
it comes from neighborly and they're
your hub for Home Services here in
Tennessee we've got mosquito the size of
turkey buzzers here they're frightening
yes they're about as big as me but
neighborly's trusted service Brands like
mosquito Joe help make sure anyone even
in the South can enjoy their backyard
all summer so go to neighborly.com to
find providers near you that's right
today's question of the day comes from
the Ramsay steps Facebook group great
communities there on Facebook and this
person says uh what baby step would you
vote as the most important
whoa It's like picking our favorite
child I know
um that's a fun question this is
interesting you know this is very this
is opinion this let's just put it out
there yes this is op-ed
um I would say that
this is like my my they're all important
it's very hard for me I mean they build
on each other right because it's a plan
so it's like one thing has to be true in
order for the next thing to be true so
on the one hand I'm like yes you've got
to get debt free like if you get debt
free that's changing your life but if
you get debt free and you never save for
retirement you're up a creek right so
I'm going to vote the non-vote oh vote
you can't do that okay well okay baby
step two is my favorite oh but it's not
the most important you put it out there
it's my favorite but it's not the most
important
that's a good way to say it they said
most important though see well George
maybe you should just okay well for
those listening like what in the
Incarnation are they talking about right
now let me just lay them out real quick
so you can cast your vote America baby
step one thousand dollar starter
emergency fund baby step two get out of
all Consumer Debt using the debt
snowball method baby step three fully
funded emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses baby step four invest
fifteen percent of your household income
into retirement baby step five put away
some money for the kids college funds
then baby step six pay off the house
early and then baby step seven build
wealth and give and be outrageously
generous so I mean you can hear that
you're like which one is the most
important which uh
I'm gonna say the most important for
your financial future is baby step four
yes investing Building Wealth being able
to retire with dignity because that is
going to give you a great life you know
20 years from now for the next 30 years
after that yeah but baby step two I
think is the most is my most favorite
and I think the most Paradigm Shift yeah
it's the most freeing yes
you know and
yeah that's that's a really good point
George because here's the thing and
here's where I kind of take this is a
lot of people will look at the baby
steps and they'll go I think these are
the most important I think it's the most
important to do baby steps one through
three and then they kind of like go off
on a tangent and do their own thing and
it's like no you don't do the baby steps
based on the ones you think are your
favorite or the ones you think are going
to be the most important you choose to
work the plan or you choose not to work
the plan that's the way I because you
know there's so many things George that
we ask people to do along the way
because we know where they're headed
like we say pause you're investing while
you're paying off debt controversial
it's controversial but we are saying
that because we know what comes next so
if you're the person who's like oh okay
I'm gonna pay off my debt but you're
like lollygagging through it and you're
not being intense like we tell you to
like these are the things that I'm
weighing in my mind they're all
important and if you're going to do this
plan
do this plan I'm gonna I'm going to
render this question as a not good
question oh wow shots fired that's a
baby steps Facebook I'm saying the
question that you need to be asking is
not this one I'm gonna try to figure out
a better question that's fair instead of
saying what baby step do you vote is
most important maybe the one that you're
on
come on George I totally went
philosophical on you that's right the
most important one is where you need to
be at if you're in debt baby step two is
the most important come on somebody if
you have no emergency savings but you
don't have any debt baby step three is
the most important I will say that you
where your feet are the Ramsay plan what
I love about it is it's more than about
money it's about transformation it's
about living counter culturally and for
that I will say baby step two is the
Crux of the plan 100 most people never
most people go through their life and
never pay off all their debt you're a
dead wolf they'll always have the most
confusing it's the most like wait what
you want me to get at all debt like cut
up the credit cards yeah and you know
Romans 12 2 do not be conformed to the
pattern of this world be transformed by
the renewing of your mind that's right
baby step two is the most
transformational renewing of the Mind
paradigm shift I can think of when you
go oh my gosh this whole world of debt
and the culture and the marketing and
consumerism it's like we're living in
the simulation yeah and if we can just
unplug and go I don't have to be a part
of that I can live on my terms I can
live with freedom and peace enjoy and
margin and options and meaning that is
what getting out of debt does for you
and then the next steps are kind of like
okay cool now we can have some money in
the bank and be investing for the future
and kind of get these things on
autopilot yeah yeah I agree with you
wholeheartedly
um I think the next controvers like
baby step two definitely different from
what culture would teach I even think
baby steps six a little bit the idea of
paying off your home mortgage early and
the way we teach a 15-year fixed rate
mortgage is economy Jade are you kidding
me they live in an alternate universe
where you can get a 15 yes math hasn't
changed since history has began I'm
sorry uh so that's a very controversial
one it is what do you think's the
hardest one oh I think baby step three
is the hardest because you're you're
done paying for the past but you're not
quite ready to build for the future yes
and it's just this not non-excitement
Midway point in the marathon there's no
one's cheering you on there's no live
band you're just kind of on your own
yeah and I think after paid off debt
during baby step two you've spent all
been all this sacrificing let's be
honest
yourself a little something something
and you're like I don't come on can I
just no can I it's time to treat
yourself that's right it's not trying
time to treat yourself oh my goodness
that's a fun conversation it is thank
you for indulging us all right Hector is
up next in San Antonio Hector welcome to
the show
hello hey how can we help
hey wow so uh thanks for taking my call
I I've been listening to the show for
about a year and uh my wife and I have
just finished paying off her vehicle so
as of last Friday we are completely debt
free
um yeah it feels good it feels really
good and the the next thing I guess
because now we we don't make a whole lot
her and I both work full-time uh she's
she's about to have to quit work for a
little while because our first child is
going to be born next month congrats
thank you thank you we're really excited
I just don't know I don't know what to
do next I I had an emergency savings and
unfortunately at our home uh the well
burned up on our property so I had to
replace the entire system and that that
set my my emergency savings back and now
I have about uh 3 600 in cash
and uh about another thousand in our
savings account in the bank
okay so you got no debt but you have 4
600 bucks liquid cash and you're about
to have a baby yeah okay so that puts
you a baby step three but you're also in
what we call stork mode because this
baby's coming we got to make sure mom
and baby are home healthy safe and we
have the funds to cover anything that
comes up
and so here's it kind of is a duel
you're doing baby step three but really
you're saving for mom and baby right now
and if mom and baby are safe and good
and healthy then that can be your baby
step three so just start building start
saving up stack up cash
don't use it don't touch it
yeah yeah that's yeah that's the hard
part right yeah we were just talking
about how baby step three is the hardest
but when it comes to having a baby when
it comes to having a baby like nothing
gives you more peace than knowing all
right like we're not focusing on
anything else it's just the well-being
of the situation and once a baby is born
at home most people hit their deductible
and have to at least meet that so
knowing that you've got that money saved
up and ready is gonna be very helpful
yeah so however much money you can save
up in the next month before baby gets
here that's your next goal
[Music]
okay it's that simple and it's that hard
I Wish I Had some life-changing like
here's the secret sauce man just save up
if you gotta get side jobs if you gotta
sell stuff now is the time to do it to
get your financial foundation in place
and then hopefully I'm praying that mom
and baby are home safe and that just
keep that stays as your uh emergency
fund you keep building on top of that
until you get to three to six months
then we begin investing that's right
just in time for baby that's fun man
you're changing your family tree proud
of you guys this is the Ramsay show
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show
we are giving you some money advice and
it's free so take that into
consideration when you call the number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five I'm George camel joined by Jade
warshaw this hour and hey if you're a
new listener and you want to dive deeper
into the Ramsay baby steps that we've
been talking about you can go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button our team has created a
really cool tool that will help you
figure out what the next best step is
for your financial Journey based on
where you're at today so go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on get
started Jonathan is up next in my
hometown Boston Massachusetts what's
going on Jonathan
how are you sir very good how are you
very good thank you for taking my call
sure
um I'm here from uh from I'm an hour
from Boston
and um I I love real estate but I'm
currently a truck driver and I uh
um
um I got two rental properties
in uh but I mean a hundred thousand
dollars of debt and I was wondering if
if I should uh just stick to
uh baby step number two and pay off like
slowly this debt of 100K or if I should
just sell one of these properties uh
because I have a good amount of equity
and just make that
um that step quicker to be um debt free
is is that 100K is that Consumer Debt or
is that including any debt on the
rentals as well
um that's uh that's
um no that's like 20 20K is is I owe for
my dad that I borrowed for the
renovation
um 40 is credit card
um and the rest is like uh it's all
split up in in different little
things like personal loans or what
um the rest is uh um I have
sorry you didn't answer my question so
the renaults are do you paid cash for
the renaults
or I'm sorry for the rentals
no no no they're not they're both
they're both financed okay what do you
owe on each rental
one of them I owe 250
uh and the other one I owe
um 500 oh my God goodness gracious are
you even cash flowing on this stuff it
sounds like you're probably breaking
even if you're lucky I don't even care
um well one of them one of them
um my mortgage is 1700.
and and I get and I get um
around like three three and a half
um I just feel like you're One Missed
step away from this house of cards
crumbling yeah with a hundred thousand
in debt and that the 40 000 in credit
cards is probably what 20 something
percent interest on that
yeah yeah trust me I that's why I'm
calling because I'm very stressed out I
I've always wanted to get into real
estate but I've never had somebody to
guide you so so
um I did like the opposite of what they
did
we've all done dumb and Dave did it with
a whole lot more zeros than we'll ever
know so it's okay we want to help you
and you can undo some of this and I
think selling the rentals is probably
part of that because right now you need
to clean slate no I I know it is George
not I think because I mean what's your
income
my income right now is it's about a 50k
a year
yeah these rentals are gone man yeah
no no if you were making 300 000 I'd be
like all right let's pay off this
hundred thousand but 50k you're gonna be
crawling for years trying to pay off
this debt
yeah so so it's like uh me and my dad we
we we kind of like we bought them
together both houses we bought them
together in both of your names
no just it's all in my name it's all in
mind this is all your debt
yeah so this is all my debt and me and
my dad are like
um we we were uh working hard on on
doing the baby step number two to pay
off this debt why is it involving is
your debt payoff forever
well because he because he uh um he
lives in in one of the the properties
and he he uh he bought it with me as
well so he's paying you rent
no no
no
yeah you said he lives so he's living in
one and you're not getting the money
every month in his rent he's just what's
he doing with that money that he would
have paid for you in rent
we're paying off debt we're paying off
um all this debt that we owe because we
we have to uh renovate and it was
um on pandemic okay and our in our
budget went over so we had to borrow
money this is I I I I
I'm not mad at you for wanting to get
into real estate I think a lot of people
do I think a lot of people see it as a
quick path to earning money or a quick
path to wealth but there's a right and a
wrong way to do it as you're learning
and I I don't I I'm sure that you feel
an enormous weight Jonathan right to
know that you owe 500k 250k and another
100K in debt and I've got to believe and
you can correct me if I'm wrong but
because you're Tangled Up in this with
your dad with a family member there's
probably a lot of pressure
right to make this writing get right
side up on this and there's some sun
cost fallacy because you guys have sunk
a lot of money into the stuff and now to
back out of all of this yeah he's like
no we just got to keep going we'll crawl
our way out we'll dig a hole all the way
through and well that's why it's a
fallacy because just because you got a
hold of it doesn't mean you can't stop
Go a different direction and sell off
this property and honestly what George
said I 100 agree I think that these
rentals need to go on the market today
both of them if you were to sell them
today uh what would you make off of each
one
um on the the one that I that I owe 500.
um which is a it's a four family on an
acre lot here in a really good uh City
okay
um I can get I could get like 400 to
500.
um inequity off that one yes inequity
hold on and I'm guessing 50 has to go to
your dad is that the the agreement
um yeah yeah that that would be the that
would be did he have the money down
yes yes uh-huh okay so let's let's
assume that I'm if you said this is a
deal you did with your dad I'm assuming
it's 50 50s so if you got 400 then you'd
get to take home 200. you're saying this
thing would sell for nine hundred
thousand
I mean it would sell for for a million I
already got it and sell for a million
and you're saying after the mortgage is
paid off after fees are taken out you
would walk away with 400 total
oh yeah uh with realtor real estate no
no okay I would Factor all that in start
to do the math but either way if you
sold one or both of these you could pay
off all of your debt
and probably start to knock out the
other rental if you just sold this one
yeah exactly so the other one it's a
three family and that one
um I owe right now around 250 on it okay
in in that one I could get 400 like 500
Max okay and then split with your dad
assuming
so you'd be bringing home about 250. so
what I really want you to go away from
this call
understanding is that a you need to sell
off these properties you need to get
debt free as soon as these properties
sell but very closely underneath that I
really want to make sure that you and
your dad are very clear on what this
deal is because in asking you it kind of
sounds like oh yeah that yeah that
sounds amazing we said that yeah we need
some real clear terms yeah written in
the contract and under overarching all
of this I understand that you and your
dad went into this as a an agreement or
a deal or something that you were going
to do together sounds like nothing's in
writing and if you're feeling some sort
of pressure from your dad to hang on to
these properties because maybe he's
living in one or he feels like he's got
money to make off of it that is
something that you guys really need to
get into because all of this is in your
name right so if you want to sell them
you can
mm-hmm right are you feeling pressure
um yeah well um I feel pressure because
like uh I live in one of the units too
so like where am I gonna put me and my
family in you're gonna have to ask my
mom my dad you're gonna have plenty of
cash after you sell these to take care
of new living situations for you and
then your dad that's up to him to decide
what he does with his portion of the
cash yeah maybe get a primary residence
where you just live there and then if
you want to buy investment property
later do it with cash but right now I'm
looking at a guy making 50k who owes
8.50 and I can't breathe man okay let's
restart and do this the right way this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Jade warshaw
this hour open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five quick
reminder that we are uh you know we're
deep in summertime now and I love
there's a Lobby full of wonderful people
who travels from all over the country to
come hang out with us maybe it's a pit
stop maybe it's the destination but I
want to invite you all to come by a lot
of people don't know look they're all
waving if you're watching on YouTube you
can come by and just hang out in the
headquarters we've got free cookies and
baked goods in the coffee shop at Baker
Street we've got a timeline wall Museum
it's a whole experience and Nashville is
a great City to visit to begin with so
for no other reason than that but we'd
love for you to come by and walk away
with a free mug free cookies smiles and
come see us through the glass like zoo
animals it's a good time well we also go
out there and talk with the people
George that's right twice an hour we'll
go out we'll take pictures and and sign
things and have a good time I love
meeting everyone hearing your stories so
there's your invitation don't say I
didn't invite you there it is let's get
to the phones Leroy is up next in Denver
Leroy welcome to the show
yes thanks for uh thanks for taking my
call can you hear me okay yeah
perfect
um so I got a quick question
um so I'm looking to pay my mortgage off
uh we paid off all our debt and right
now we're doing extra payments my
question is
I'm considering reducing my contribution
to my 401k right now I'm contributing to
20 percent
and I'm contemplating reducing that down
to like 10 percent
um to get more
money on the check and pay more towards
my mortgage
uh right now I'm at
um
under 100 000 to to pay off our mortgage
so the the end is getting we're getting
closer and I'm eagerly wanting to just
pay it off and I was wondering if you
think that'd be a good idea
Chords it's a great question and I love
that you're a gun hole about paying this
thing off and you're seeing the light at
the end of the tunnel and you're getting
a little antsy and that can cause us to
do some extreme things and you've been
extreme on the investing side and I say
we split the difference yeah and come
down to 15 mm-hmm
yeah I love that idea 15.
yeah that I mean that's the amount that
we would suggest 15 of your gross and
then that's gonna obviously give you
five percent more than what you had
before to put towards retirement and
you're still I'm sorry to put towards
your mortgage and you're able to be as
in intense as you'd like to be uh with
that
so what would that do to the mortgage if
you went down to 15 how much money would
that free up how how much faster would
to speed up this home pay off
so it'll free up about a thousand
dollars a month extra
mortgage payments yeah wow you guys must
have an awesome income
um we're doing really well so all my
income goes to the bills my wife's
income goes to the mortgage so we we
make about a payment and a half each
month and I'd like to double it
um and if I can get it paid off in like
a year or maybe two years then then we
become completely debt free yeah and
then we can really round up investing
exactly so and you're so you're saying
uh drop it down to at least 15 percent
it's right at 15 until the house is paid
off and then once you're there you can
bump it up to twenty percent twenty five
thirty five percent do what you want
increase your giving increase some of
your spending and enjoy some of it and I
think that's a well-balanced approach to
all of this that's exciting okay you're
going to be there yeah you're gonna be
there in a year you said
I'd like to I mean I'd like to go out
aggressively I right now if I can do two
thousand dollars a month I can probably
get it paid off in about three years
that's great how old are you Leroy
I just turned 50. way to go way to go
that's exciting stuff huge part of your
wealth building journey and it's going
to help your retire with dignity and
maybe even early at this point I mean
imagine having no house payment and
being able to invest 30 of your income
that's the plan we we bumped it up to 20
when uh when the stock tanked and we
just we've been at it about 20 percent
for a little over a year and a half and
it's grown pretty pretty good we're
happy where we're at so I'm to the point
where I I'm I've got enough in there to
where I can cut back a little bit and uh
just go after the mortgage to be
completely debt free that's awesome I'm
proud of you and you've got some ketchup
contributions too once you hit 50 which
is going to only help your wealth
building Journey at this point so that's
right love that you guys are changing
family tree man thanks for the question
Bree is up next in Indianapolis Bree
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thank you yeah what's going on
um
hi my husband and I recently lost my
in-laws both of them two months of each
other
but we are going to be inheriting
some money from them and we just kind of
wanted to know what was the next step
um we've never inherited money before
and so we just want to make sure we're
doing it right
um we're going to be getting about 80
000 cash and then um I think around 200
and
160 or so in Investments
um we just weren't sure the only debt we
have so far is or currently is our
mortgage so we're trying to decide do we
roll those investments into
another investment account or leave
those alone or do we go to paying off
our mortgage just kind of what's the
next step
yeah great question well I'm so sorry to
hear about your in-laws was it just a
health related old age or what what one
was a complete surprise had heart
surgery and then ended up with MRSA and
passed away
um and then my mother-in-law had been
fighting a year-long battle of cancer
wow so it was just a lot in a couple
months yeah well I hope you guys leave
some space to grieve and uh you're
wanting to approach this wisely but we
always say don't make any big moves
after something like this happens
something traumatic something you've got
to grieve so it's okay to just let that
money sit for six months in a savings
account okay or in the investment
account so don't feel like we've got to
do something with this now next what is
left on your mortgage
um we've got 300 000 left okay and you
have an emergency fund and no Consumer
Debt yes
yes nope great and you're already
investing 15 percent
uh yes
um we've been investing for probably 15
years now so we've got a pretty decent
investment what kind of portfolio saved
up cool and do you know what these
Investments are that you are inheriting
I think that's that's we're meeting with
them next week that's why I wanted to
call and get your guys's opinion and
have a heads up before I went in there
but I believe they're IRAs all right
so I would obviously look into the tax
implications if you did you know
withdraw this money you want to make
sure you do it wisely so I would kind of
set up a team around you as you inherit
this money and you want to walk wisely
number one get a good investment Pro in
your corner we call them smart Vester
pros and we can connect you with one at
ramseysolutions.com the other that you
can also get connected with there is a
tax Pro
to understand all the tax implications
and what this means you know with the
IRS come tax time because I don't want
you guys to have a huge burden you
weren't expecting when you cash it out
paid off the mortgage and we're
celebrating and now the IRS is like you
owe us sixty thousand dollars that was
our other fear because I didn't know
what all came with that and I know
different states are have different
taxes on inheritance so exactly so
everything's going to be State specific
you know depending on what kind of
Investments and if taxes have already
been paid on those Investments you know
with a Roth account for example there'll
be different implications so just make
sure you do due diligence there but my
goal for you guys would be to get that
house paid off
and that's kind of where we're at too is
man we're so close and we were planning
on having having it paid off within
eight to ten years we've been playing
paying double payments for quite a while
and
um so it doesn't sound like you have a
fantastic income
way better than it's ever
like 95 000 so it's not a lot but we
just
like the baby steps and you guys have
definitely changed our lives we started
following you when we got married and
have just been really almost baby steps
and we're trying to get our house paid
off and moving on to that next step so
very good well uh you know this I think
this will get us there yeah hopefully
sometime and it's a silver lining what a
blessing and Legacy they left you guys
instead of a pile of mess they left you
with this incredible blessing that
propels your financial future and helps
you guys so so thankful for that because
they were probably two of the most
selfless people that I know and did
everything for their family and so I
know this is a huge blessing and we want
to honor that for them and do what we
can to keep our family stable and
incredible incredible stuff well you
sounds like you guys are on track
financially I would use much of that
money as you can to pay off this
mortgage and looking into all the
implications and taxes and all that but
once you do that you'll still have money
left over so keep a lot of that
Investments and keep it rolling way to
go thanks so much for the call that it's
this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books my thanks to my co-host Jade
warshaw all the folks in the booth
keeping the show float and you America
thank you for listening we'll be back
before you know it
[Music]
foreign
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell Join This Hour by Jade warshaw
and we are taking your calls at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is a show that is about you it's
for you we want to see you win in every
area of your life and of course money is
a huge part of that and Jade and I would
be happy to walk you through your
burning questions celebrate your
successes and help you make that right
Next Step financially
888-825-5225 Gage kicks us off in
Sacramento Gage welcome to the show
all right thank you how you guys doing
today we're doing great how are you
I'm doing well
okay so I had a quick question
um I have about twenty thousand dollars
worth of credit card debt right now I'm
just turned 25.
um I also still owe about 9 000 on my
car what I'm calling about is I'm
currently in the process of getting into
a flight school in San Diego that's
going to be taken up about two years of
my time uh full-time schooling so I'm
curious uh what's the best way to go
about this debt uh I've talked to some
people who has recommended like a
bankruptcy to just wipe the Slate Queen
so once I get a career I'm not still
drowning in that debt I just kind of
wanted to get you guys opinion and uh
who is some people who did you talk to
uh
probably not the smartest people I don't
have a ton of financially uh literate
friends oh it is your friends like us
broke people for financial advice and
they gave it to you declare bankruptcy
Clean Slate it's going to help your
career
yeah I didn't think it sounds that smart
all that smart you knew you knew that
was bad advice you're here calling us so
I'm glad you didn't make that move yet
because it's absolutely not the move you
should be making
thank you what's your income
uh making about 48 per year
will that change with flight school
so while I while I'm in flight school I
don't believe I'll be making income uh
it's the school is going to be 100
accredited uh by the VA so okay so
you're not paying a dime for the school
no wow that's incredible flight school
is expensive
yeah it is it is not cheap
okay so school's covered how are you
going to pay for the bills do you have
any bills at that point
are they covering room and board or use
small bills that could be paid with
um you know just Uber Lyft doordash
things like that I was kind of figuring
like free time yeah are you able to work
the whole time
uh so I'm not sure exactly what the the
schedule will look like I currently
worked full-time I've worked full time
since I was 17 I just turned 25 so okay
how long till flight school starts
I'm planning on starting in January so
uh about five months okay that's good my
question is can we clean this debt up in
five months you think you could do that
I believe so like I said I just I've
kind of how I've grown up I haven't
grown up around a lot of financially
literate people so I don't really know
the steps to start taking I just found
our Dave Ramsey a couple weeks ago I've
been watching you know the baby steps
and watching a lot of his content and uh
just trying to get ahead here well we
can help you with the steps um just a
quick question are you gonna have a
housing allowance once you start
doing that flight school through the VA
yeah so that's uh that's still in the
process I'm not 100 sure yet okay if I'm
not then I'm I'll 100 have to have to
find you know a real steady source of
income but I mean I'm not too worried
about that I don't have any problem you
know finding a job or working do you
have any money
I don't I've been living paychecks
paycheck for the past few years now and
uh most of that is all my fault just
making dumb decisions but uh I want to
start getting ahead and getting things
together
self-awareness is the first step so I'm
proud of you for even owning that
instead of just blaming everything and
everyone else for the problems that
tells me you're going to get out of this
thing so what is the car this was uh
pretty much just me
you said what is the car worth yeah
uh I believe they're blue books I
probably looked it up a couple months
ago somewhere around ten five okay so
I'm just thinking if you really wanted
to get out I want you out of debt by
flight school so that you have a life
and you know you can work to pay the
bills but you're not trying to also
tackle all this debt and you've got some
time you've got five months to really go
hard at this thing and work extra and do
the Uber and lift on top of your
full-time job and if you threw you know
five or six k a month of this thing it's
gone so the question is what is that Gap
to where we need we need to make to get
five or six k a month thrown at the debt
yeah
uh uh because right now what's your
take-home pay
my take-home pay uh right around 2 000
per check
oh yeah and I get paid bi-weekly okay so
bringing in about four grand a month
and obviously you got to make your debt
payments you have rent right now
yes but my rent is very cheap how cheap
uh currently paying about 600 a month
okay good that is cheap for Sacramento I
was like cheap for Californians is very
different like it's only three grand a
month that's cheap no good job yeah no
yeah that's great like I said I have
been kind of a fool with my money so I
need to start getting that I mean at the
end of the day when it comes to paint
wanting to pay off debt it's a pretty
simple equation you know we're trying to
uh lower our expenses as much as
possible while simultaneously increasing
our income as much as possible in order
to have as much money as possible to
throw out this debt so that's what
you're looking to do that should be the
uh the
mindset that you filter all of your
choices through for the next five months
is is this going to bring my expenses
down or is this going to drive my income
up and so that's that's the idea here
for the next five months and then once
you get into flight school you're going
to kind of have to reevaluate your
situation find out what your time is
going to be like find out if you're
getting a home allowance because if you
are that's great that frees up some
money find out how much you're going to
be able to work so you've kind of got
two equations that you're looking at one
is the the now and the current and the
next one is here in the future what
that's going to look like with your new
um obligations in Flight School what's
your car payment
uh my car payment 256 per month okay
it may not be worth selling the car
because I think you can pay it off
pretty quickly and you'd have to go
around and buy something else anyways
and you don't have any money to do that
so I would attack that car payment first
I mean I know you got the credit card
debt are those multiple cards
uh it's two cards yes so what's the
lowest balance the majority of the
amount is on one card and then uh about
like a thousand is on the other okay and
then it's making the Opera the the
choice also to say I'm not using credit
cards anymore so if you haven't yet cut
up these credit cards make sure you've
cut those up once they're paid off close
out
I haven't used a credit card and like
some months now okay great so you've
learned your lesson there never to go
back again very good all right so I'm
gonna gift you one year of financial
based University and one year of every
dollar premium to help you on this
journey making a plan for every one of
those dollars creating that margin
seeing the progress learning the steps
because you said you're new to all this
stuff so that is my gift to you uh not
only as a veteran but someone who's new
to this program and we're thankful for
you Gage so hang on the line we'll gift
that to you and for all of the rest of
you listening who might be jealous
because Gage has got some free stuff we
have an awesome limited time deal right
now if you want to jump in on every
dollar you want the premium version 15
bucks off and a two week free trial to
check it out you can go to
everydollar.com George and get that deal
tell them I sent you won't ya so uh
that's it the plan is that simple and
it's that hard there's no magic tricks
here there's no secret sauce you are the
secret sauce spend less make more throw
as much as the debt as possible get some
emergency Savings in the bank then you
can start building for the future there
is no other way you cannot convince this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Jade warshaw
this hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number to call
if you want to jump in and talk about
your life and your money
well Jay the news of the last uh week or
two has been the student loan payments
restarting that's right I know that's
right which has caused a lot of people
to start panicking for good reason
they're freaking out because they have
not been budgeting for this payment they
haven't been making payments that's
right one stat showed 99 of people did
not make payments which I don't know why
because we told people to make payments
don't wait on the government one percent
of the people listened to us and they
went oh yeah we've been debt free now
for like years Jade yeah that's right we
got rid of it we're not even worried
about that we don't care about the
headlines so here's the headline from
Yahoo the restart of student loan
payments is going to pressure the strong
U.S consumer as 34 of borrowers say
they'll be unable to make payments I
think that that is very conservative
that 34 that's just the honest people
yeah because think about it George
before this in 2019 before this pause
ever even happened 50 of people were
either in default forbearance they were
not paying their loan so I can't
understand what has changed to bring
that down to 34 so I think that's being
very conservative yeah the average
payment is between uh 300 to 400 bucks
and only 29 of consumers who have
federal student loans are confident
they'll have enough money to start
making payments without adjusting
spending in other areas Morgan Stanley
said meanwhile 37 said they'll need to
cut their spending in other areas to
make the payments while 34 said they
won't be able to make them at all and in
this case the restart of payments will
negatively impact low-income households
the most according to the survey well
yeah let's be a lot of shockers there
well no because people said when this
pause happened they were like oh I've
got this money back in my budget I mean
we've seen the stats that said most
people that on average earned 15
thousand dollars back from not having to
make their payments right and so that
money George was not spent on paying
down their loan it just went towards I'm
guessing car notes it probably felt like
they got a raise yeah they were like I'm
living lifestyle creep yeah yeah well
this says a segment of consumers start
to feel the pressure heading into the
fall discretionary spending categories
could see the biggest decline if
consumers need to tighten their belts
you think no duh we're gonna need to
stop spending money on crap we didn't
need to buy
basic yes article is just brilliant you
know yes it's highlighting what I think
is very obvious which is people had this
money to spend now they're not going to
have this money anymore we need to make
a change we need to make a change and
the biggest thing is like don't let this
mess around and creep up on you you know
you've got there's a little bit of
leeway here for people to start looking
at their budgets start looking at their
lifestyle and going okay I know this
payment's coming back I'm not going to
bury my head in the sand I'm going to
start figuring out what this means for
me yep Christmas is on December 25th
every year yeah July 4th is on July 4th
every year fun fact that's right
Grandma's birthday that's right don't
act surprised and here's the scary part
Jade here's another article that was
very worrisome from MSN student loan
quote hack backfires after forgiveness
fails so here's what happened the
Department of Education suggests 9
million borrowers are eligible for
refunds for the payments they made at
any point during the student loan
moratorium that's been in place since
March of 2020. borrowers have received
refunds how many borrowers have received
refunds remains unclear but many of
those who did were banking on
forgiveness leading them to use the cash
for other expenses so tldr let me tell
you what happened here yes the student
loan company said hey you've made all
these payments we can just refund you
that money and people thought wow that's
amazing here's what they did they
reinstated your loan balance yes so if
they gave Jade a ten thousand dollar
refund for ten thousand dollars in
payments she made they give you the
check but they also reinstate the loan
balance so she owes ten thousand dollars
then they said all right good luck the
government will forgive them right
you'll be fine and here they are so you
would have had to hold on to that ten
thousand dollars until Biden's
Administration said go and I bet my
bottom ten thousand dollars that very
few people did that I
George our money is gone I follow folks
on social media number one so many poo
poo influencers were telling people to
do this George peop this is why you
can't you got to be so careful where you
take your financial advice so many
influence we're saying influencers are
saying yeah go get your refund get your
money just hang on to it it wasn't a
stimulus check and I know these people I
have seen them now posting going holy
crap there's not going to be forgiveness
I spent that money and now I'm back in
debt you tune up 10 and 20. yeah you
paid off your debt and they gave you
another loan essentially is what
happened yes and nobody hung on to that
money it's like it was like Radioactive
in your account you know you've got this
ten thousand dollars back and ten
thousand I mean that's a trip George
that is that's a down payment on a house
you know or towards it people used this
money because it was just sitting there
like a hot potato in their account and
now they're up a creek because they're
back to where they were yeah because it
didn't that forgiveness did not come
come through and it's not coming through
and I hate that for them
y'all stop listening to politicians Stop
Believing in their false promises stop
listening to influencers who are telling
you to do stupid stuff it's Common Sense
get out of debt stay out of debt have
money in the bank invest for the future
and when you do that whenever that
carrot tries to dangle in front of your
ca your face you'll just slap it out of
the way that's right you won't even care
about it and you need to be on a budget
if you're not today and figure out where
you're going to cut spending because
this article is telling us people are
going to have to make some changes in
there but yeah you think yeah you got to
figure out how not only you're going to
make the 400 minimum payment but how
you're going to be able to put 400 bucks
on top of that that's on top of that to
get rid of this debt once and for all so
you know we got some Flack for our post
we did Jade about the social the student
loan forgiveness like they're happy and
they're gloating no I'm not happy here's
why I'm happy the ball's back in your
court that's right you're not wishing
and hoping and watching the carrot
dangle in front of you you're like crap
I'm I'm in control now it's my
responsibility what am I going to do
next if I'm you I am and I have been you
by the way I have had student loans and
I had student loans back in 0809 during
the Great Recession the worst time ever
economically in my lifetime and if I'm
you I'm getting on every dollar tonight
I'm downloading it if I never had it
before if you're not sure what every
dollar is it is our
budgeting software here at Ramsay it's
the best software out there and I'm
gonna start looking at my budget I'm
going to put it's easy to load the
numbers in I'm going to start looking at
what am I making I'm going to list all
my expenses in there and I'm going to
look to see okay what is it gonna look
like for me because if you don't have
money saved yeah you might need to put a
little money aside if you've got other
debt besides your student loans you
might have to start on those first while
you're making minimum payments on
student loans but every dollar is going
to help you see all that listed out guys
and you're going to see how quickly get
this because I know I'm about to blow
your mind you could actually pay off
your student loans and not just make boo
boo minimum payments that's what got us
into this mess people have been paying
on this stuff for 20 years yeah and
they're mad because their balance has
increased because they're not making
enough payments if your interest is high
enough or you went to forbearance or one
yeah one of these shortcuts or these
income based repayment plans which are
the worst because you never pay off the
debt the balance just skyrockets yeah
you got to get out of this thing by
making extra payments that's the day
that snowball smallest to largest
minimum payments on everything except
for that first one and the smallest one
we attack and how would it feel George I
know you've been there I've been there
we've all been in the situation where
economically everything's going crazy
and you're in it you're right in the
middle of the tornado getting caught up
in all the economic political stuff how
good does it feel to Fly Above That to
finally get that out of your life to
where you're not part of it guys this
stuff goes in Cycles okay this is not
the last we're ever going to hear about
forgiveness this is not the last time
we're ever going to have a weird economy
okay next time make it like put it in
stone next time you're flying above this
by the time this circles back around
again your life financially is going to
be in order and you are going to just
sit back and watch everybody else be
weird and get you know be worried about
this stuff and your your loans are going
to be gone make that your choice today
don't get caught up again right on
average it takes folks following these
baby steps 18 to 24 months to get out of
all consumer debts come on 20 years
uh-uh two years I was out for a plan I
remember paying off my 36 Grand in
student loans and I was ubering I was
lifting I was living on Lean Cuisines
Jay and I got lean I'll tell you I was
lean and I was doing everything I could
to get rid of that debt as fast as
possible and I it was so freeing to not
have to wait on someone else to do it
for me
and so make a plan get on a budget do
what it takes come celebrate with us
when you're debt free and we'll
celebrate the fact uh that you're not
waiting on no man no woman no politician
to change your life it's something you
are the secret sauce America this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Jade warshaw this
hour and we want to help you we want to
take your calls at AAA
825-5225 if you got a question about
your life your money we want to give you
that right Next Step and be somewhat of
an unbiased third party I can't say
completely unbiased because we have bias
towards you winning and getting out of
debt and that's technically a bias so
I'll give you that but if you need a
third party opinion that's not your
broke brother-in-law the in-laws that
don't have boundary issues you know
there's a lot of pressure and a lot of
noise and a lot of inputs in our life
social media you saw a video and you're
like is that true is this a tax hack I'm
like no that's that's called fraud
please don't do that yeah we don't have
a dog in the hunt we just want you to
win we just tell you the truth even if
it hurts a little bit Ashley's up next
in Wichita Ashley welcome to the show
you with us Ashley
I am yes good good how can we help today
great
awesome thanks so much for answering my
question
um my situation is
uh I will be graduating college debt
free I own my car and I've built up some
savings and I've opened up retirement
accounts so I'm wondering what should my
next steps be in my financial Journey
what goals doing are you raised by a
unicorn how did you get here Ashley
you're in such great shape talks about
money in front of us it was a normal
dinner conversation so I've always grown
up with an awareness of responsible
savings and realistic expenses that's so
awesome and there's a lesson for your
parents out there don't be scared to
talk about money do it in a healthy way
when exactly do you graduate
um my expected graduation is in 2026
. okay and it's already all paid for
um I have a 529
um with more than enough to cover all of
my college expenses great fantastic okay
and you're saying hey what should my
next steps be now you've got obviously
education for the next three years that
you're focused on are you able to work
part-time while you're in school
um I'm working a couple hours a week on
campus so my take home is about two
thousand dollars a year two thousand a
year okay but we're just kind of just
covering you don't have any bills right
now
correct since room and Boards covered
all that your meals okay
so your next steps obviously is to
actually graduate by 2026 or earlier if
you can
and leave college with as much money as
possible to start your adult life that's
right stack it up and that might mean
all right we need a car uh we need it
first and last month's deposit for rent
we need some money for a down payment on
a house eventually so you've got some
big financial goals ahead of you but the
next one that's right in front of you is
investing in Ashley
investing what I'm earning
um I have I have built up enough savings
where I'd feel comfortable with rent and
transitioning out of school would you
recommend investing what I'm taking home
from my on-campus job or putting that
into savings how much do you have in
savings so far
um I have around 11 000 in savings oh
yeah I look if I were you I would
continue to save money simply because by
the time you and 11k don't get me wrong
especially for where you are in your age
it feels like a lot of money but when
you actually get out into the world and
you graduate you're gonna find that by
the time you're getting an apartment
Maybe by then it's time to upgrade a
view like once you really get into there
that money although great now you know
you're gonna want as much as possible by
the time you graduate so I probably
would not invest anything plus you know
you got three years to go before you
graduate if you were saying oh I'm gonna
invest as a savings vehicle it still
doesn't make sense because it's too
short of a time frame yeah and so you
said you're earning about 2 000 a year
truthfully once you get out in the real
world and you're making forty fifty
sixty thousand that's when you should be
investing because the numbers change
drastically and so if you put that 11
000 in a high yield savings account you
could get four or five percent right now
we'll call it 500 bucks a year and
that's I'm going to call that good and
it's not about the the interest in the
investing portion it's about protecting
Ashley's Financial World portion and so
you're going to make 40 50 bucks a month
on that savings account and that's
totally fine if you invested it you
might make a hundred bucks a month you
might lose 100 bucks a month and I don't
want you worrying about that while
you're trying to graduate debt free and
kind of start this adult life you're
gonna have plenty of time how old are
you
and 19. 19 years old you were so far
ahead of the game you are going to be a
multi-millionaire if you just follow
this path graduate debt free begin
investing as soon as you get your first
full-time job you're going to do so well
what I love is that you're eager to
start exercising that muscle I think
that's so great keep that fire but do it
at the right time and focus on one thing
at a time yeah thank you so much for the
call Ashley love hearing that inspiring
Sam is up next in Chicago Sam welcome to
the Ramsay show
hey guys good afternoon how are you
doing great how can we help
so uh I'm calling because I just created
a budget just kind of actually a new job
and just trying to figure out how to pay
down some debt uh big big fan of you
guys watched you guys and understand
baby steps but uh I got 140 000 in
student loans and um trying to figure
out my highest priority to take care of
first well you've got the expert here
Jade warshaw who paid off close to half
a million in Consumer Debt and uh so she
can definitely walk you through exactly
what this is going to look like so tell
us about the debt what is this breakdown
sure so I got 29 913 uh in navient uh
private student loans which is the
highest priority two loans um one is at
the variable
14.75 and then that's only 6 500 left
which is my top priority I think to pay
off especially because it's the highest
uh interest rate and then the rest uh 25
000 is the difference in the private
loan coming through like you said is no
net which is the public loan that's the
big chunk of things ninety seven
thousand one hundred and eighty dollars
one big loan and then I actually yes
public loans
and then um do have a lease that's
coming uh due or for Finance in January
which is about 13 000. so I think just
financially it makes more sense to just
pay that off the rest residual value
rather than you know having to get
another used car or something cheaper or
either in brand new car so what do you
guys think okay so let me just make sure
I understand this so we've got the loans
you've got private and you've got
Federal the federal ones that were 97
000 even though they're all federal
sometimes they're broken down honestly
like by the semester you took it so it's
like yeah is it broken down in any other
way or is it it wasn't just one loan for
97 000 was it no no yeah you're right it
is broken down by semester they're like
sixty five hundred dollars until summer
two thousand somewhere thousands okay
but it all equates that so you probably
have like 13 or 15 different loans that
make that up the reason I'm asking is
because when we attack this debt not
just the student loan debt but all of
your debt we're we're doing the debt
snowball okay so what that means is
we're listing all of the debt no matter
where it's from what type of debt it
doesn't matter all of it smallest to
largest buy balance not by interest rate
and don't get me wrong when it comes to
student loans sometimes the first
thought is like dude I gotta pay off
this other one first because the
interest rate's 14 and it's a private
loan I really want to
um push you to not go that direction I
want you to go by balance and the reason
I'm telling you that my husband and I we
had 280 000 okay a lot of most of them
were private um so I feel you
wholeheartedly right now
um but something happens
um in your motivation when you do it
smallest to largest because it's like
okay
it there comes a time where you start
looking at it by number of debts as
opposed to amount of debts right and
when you are able to go from I don't
know 16 or 18 debts down to 12 debts it
just feels great even if the balance too
soon I'm saying even if the balance was
only six thousand you feel great because
you're like wow I had this list of 18
and now I only have a list of 16. so I
want to challenge you to start looking
at it in that way do the stat snowball
and just start working that thing out
you're going to be surprised at how
quickly this goes what's your income
105. all right look
Now's the Time we're busting that income
up we're doing whatever it takes to get
more money side Hustle sell stuff work
on the side whatever it is but just
remember keep going on that debt
snowball it is going to work you're
going to start feeling the difference
yeah start to do the math and go hey I
want to get this thing out of my life in
two or three years what do I got to do
to get there it might mean you got to go
get a second job a third job sell some
stuff not do the lease drive a beater
car those are all the sacrifices that
are worth it short term so you can have
long-term Freedom you can do it you got
the same this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Jade warshaw the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five five two two five if you're
listening to this show which you've got
to be if you're hearing this I would ask
you to do one thing the show is free
what I'm asking you to do is free and
that is if you like the show please
share it subscribe wherever you're
hanging out with us hit the follow
button leave a review tell a friend all
of that stuff matters so much we have a
very slim marketing budget around here
because you guys are the marketing
budget and really that's the way life
change happens that's right Jay tells me
oh you gotta go check out this podcast
it's not a promoted ad on Twitter it's
not the Instagram story ad it's a friend
telling a friend hey this stuff affected
my life it changed my life it got me
motivated to get out of debt invest the
right way you've got to check this out
so tell them about the show that's good
we appreciate that
all right let's get to the phones Anna
awaits in St Louis Anna welcome to the
show
hi hey what's going on
I just got a little States right
it's just me
thank you for uh taking my call I'm
really excited to talk to you guys I
just I'm a new listener and um so far
you've given me quite a bit of helpful
advice so
um I will just kind of jump into it um
my situation has quite a few layers I
think it's important to understand that
my husband so my husband and I were both
39 years old we have two small kids
three years old and five years old my
husband has been recently diagnosed with
a rare liver condition called Wilson's
disease and
um he's essentially disabled so now he
receives receives SSDI he's been
disabled for quite a while but
um diagnosing this condition has been
very difficult and he's only received
that diagnosis in those past year and he
has a pretty strong
background in finance he worked for the
Federal Reserve of New York for quite of
some time he began his career at PWC so
he's always been kind of the um the
financial person in the household and
was making the big decisions for us when
we first met we had good plans for our
future and then things started to kind
of go Haywire he started getting sick
um and essentially the symptoms of this
condition
um they progressed over time and if you
don't identify it soon enough the
symptoms get get worse and the weight
presents itself is it looks like he has
Parkinson's and it looks like he um he
has he has cognitive impairments as well
so I've essentially become his legal
guardian and conservator so the last
several years have been
um essentially kind of survival mode and
you know essentially us living or me
Living on a Prayer every day trying to
figure out just survival mode yeah
really what to figure out what to do for
our family and
um you know
um
we've
at this point where we are I'll just
kind of jump to where we are at this
point I've already
um paid down about 15 000 in debt that
we've had
um I still have about 12 more thousand
to pay off
um our gross um no our income uh the uh
end of the month is about ten thousand
dollars so theoretically we should be
doing okay but because we've had so much
going on in the past few years
um
I really just my head hasn't been clear
um making so many really scary decisions
have been difficult so at this point
trying to figure out how to kind of plan
for those unknown things
um planning for his medical care
planning for our kids future planning
for our retirements I mean we don't we
don't have any assets we really just
don't have anything right now truthfully
we have a small
401K in his name that has about twenty
thousand dollars
um and that's pretty much it
uh so Anna tell me this you have twelve
thousand dollars in debt left you're
making ten thousand a month you're
trying to budget for the future what
kind of debt is this and how quickly can
we get it out of the way so that we can
budget for the future with some more
margin
I think that um you know I've since I
started educating myself and looking at
kind of um the advice you guys have been
giving I think that it would be
reasonable to pay it off in the next
three months or so
um and start fresh
um
so I think we could get there pretty
quickly
um I'm trying to be conservative with
our spending and only you know buy what
we need at this point
um I just know that things come up and
especially I don't know when you know
when we're sometimes we'll have doctor
visits and it's not like regular I can't
always plan ahead for what kind of
doctor visits he's going to have we've
been to hospital visits multiple times
in the last year we've had so many
things going on then he has medications
and all the things all of these things
you know do you guys have good health
care where does that provided through
so he um being a federal employee he
retained his his
um Federal Reserve benefits and
continues to have that
um out of pocket max
um
I don't I don't think so he his coverage
is pretty good but he also recently just
got Medicare since he's been disabled
for at least two years so he has that
and that's very helpful but things
um you know there are still
uncertainties
um given his rare condition a lot of
times doctors don't really know what to
do with it so since we're fairly close
to Chicago I found a clinic out there
that specifically treats Wilson's
disease so I'm going to be making the
trips to go there regularly so that's
you know that's a drive that's a hotel
that's a whole other it expense because
I need him to get the best care I can
get him
um and then thinking about our kids I
want to make sure that they are
financially safe
um and that our we can plan for our
retirement and we are also you know Anna
you're doing an amazing job I just want
to give you some credit here because
what you've been going through is so so
unimaginably difficult and you're gonna
have to give yourself Grace that your
financial future might look different
than what you guys had planned and like
Dr deloni might say you've got to grieve
what happened and then make a plan for
what's next and look at the actual
reality of the situation and that might
mean it's going to take us a little
longer to get out of that it's going to
take us a little longer to save up for
the kids college and we just have to
learn what this new normal looks like
yeah I think you know I think that
you've been in survival mode for so long
and you're a great manager of your
household you've done such a good job
and you've looked at every detail and
now you're continuing to do that it's
like what about this what about that
what about that and I honestly think
walking through this plan you've got a
good income and that's the that's the
blessing in all of this is you have the
money I think to do what it is that you
need to do I think for somebody like you
having a nice savings cushion is going
to be something that gives you a lot of
peace of mind because like you said you
don't always know what these doctors
visits are going to be you don't always
know what's at the end of the at the end
of the line here but just rest in
knowing that you're doing such an
excellent job I mean the fact that you
could have come in here said and said
that you had hundreds and thousands of
dollars of debt and you had 12K you know
so I think or I'm sorry 10K
12K yes so I think that you're doing
such a good job I just want to tell you
that you know from my own mouth great
job you know
that's all I can say
well and I want to say one more thing
the big thing for you is making sure
that you've got your defense and having
good insurance in place so I want you to
go take our coverage checkup you can do
that at ramseysolutions.com checkup and
I want you to check on all of your
coverage with these Pros to go hey do I
have enough coverage am I getting the
best rate some people might find they
save 600 bucks on home and auto just
like that some people might find hey
we're actually underinsured on this side
we need to be in better coverage here
because that's going to protect what you
have in place and protect your future
and give you that peace of mind but the
faster we can get out of debt and the
faster we get this emergency fund in
place which I would lean to six months
for you guys because of your financial
situation and health situation that's
going to give you that peace of mind and
I think you're going to get there fast
making are you going to stay making 10
grand a month is that consistent
um there is potentially I could get more
so I
um been able to I am a speech therapist
I've been able to open up a Private
Practice Clinic that has kind of grown
fairly quickly and I have a business
partner and um this is kind of our this
is our second year in and we've expanded
fairly quickly and um
that is for now the income that we've
agreed upon but there is potential for
bonuses and growth and more and so the
that you know that was one of my
I guess this is kind of my retirement
plan and essentially was trying to
protect our this is the only way new
house so this is what we did you guys
are so young and I feel very confident
that you know at 39 years old you still
got plenty of life to invest and to
build that wealth to get that nest egg
and get that cushion and you'll get
there I'm going to give you one year of
every dollar premium to help you as you
guys navigate this budget and plan for
the future so hang on the line and
Christian will hook you up with one year
of every dollar very thankful for the
call this is the Ramsey Show
what's up guys it's Jay
it's Jay Journey we have
we have newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell join this hour by the
incredible Jade warshaw and we are
taking your calls at AAA
825-5225 if you've got a question you've
been a long time listener you want to be
a first-time caller today is your day
call us up we would love to help you
take the right next step with your life
and your money Kua is kicking us off in
Greenville South Carolina cool welcome
to the show
hi George how are you hi Jade hi we are
doing so great how can we help you
um so I wanted to get your thoughts on
sinking funds outside of our four walls
if we're still paying off debt do you
guys believe in having sinking funds or
is it everything you have paid toward
debt this is a great question
conversation pretty juicy nobody wants
to have these kinds of conversations
cool when I'm at dinner parties nobody's
like let's talk sinking funds I like
this question I know you could have been
great for it so well here's our thing
with sinking funds when you're in debt
you do the sinking funds for the things
that you absolutely need to have sinking
funds for so the vacation sinking fund
cut is gone the insurance thinking fund
we need to keep that
so what's what kind of sinking funds are
you talking about
I thought you would say that about
vacations that wanted to make sure do
you have the vacation sinking fund
you're like I hope he lets me keep that
one no no you don't have it but there's
nothing in it okay good I feel like the
car one is the one that's kind of on the
fence because obviously your car has
normal you know wear and tear and so
you've got to have the maintenance on it
um it's not something but here's my
thing it's if you can cash flow it or
not
so when it comes to vehicle maintenance
if you're able to cash flow you know
getting the new tire or you know getting
the oil changed then I probably wouldn't
do a sinking fund because you know that
particular month you're taking away 12
or 15 you know whatever it is you're
taking that away from your debt snowball
as opposed to hey I just know in August
I'm getting an oil change and I'm going
to put aside the I don't know how even
how much an oil change costs these days
but it depends if it's synthetic or
regular or blend I don't even know what
you're saying
my husband likes the synthetic so do you
see what I'm saying like it can be
tempting to make a zillion sinking funds
but at the end of the day it's like hey
look I'm trying to pay off debt I need
as much of my income as I can every
single month to put towards that debt
um and if you can cash flow at cash flow
and you have a thousand bucks right the
starter emergency fund yes yes so think
about it this way could I cover what
that sinking fund was aiming towards
with the starter emergency fund flat
tire we can cover with a starter
emergency fund and the oil change we can
figure that out in cash flow in the
budget when we know it's coming up that
following month so I would try to plan
ahead and just put things in the budget
and only leave syncing funds for things
you absolutely need yeah now if you had
a car this is just you know for fun if
somebody had a car George and they're
like my car's on its last leg
I feel like it's about to go out
should I do a sinking fund to start
putting aside for an upgraded vehicle
what would you say I probably wouldn't
do it I think we I would cross that
bridge when I get there because a lot of
people are like the car's on this last
leg it could go seven more you never
know right yeah you never know so when
the time comes time to do a repair we're
going to figure out how to cash flow
that well you pause the baby steps
temporarily stack up cash sell stuff
side jobs whatever you got to do to get
back on the road good does that answer
your question Kua I don't know that we
were super helpful um am I able to
answer follow-ups yeah or ask a
follow-up um I wanted to know what your
thoughts were for saving up for the
marriage and money getaway oh on baby
step two yes oh no girl I don't know
girl ah I consider that a luxury
entertainment yes item and I wish I wish
I could be like cool we're gonna send
you for free I don't know that I have
the power to do that I don't think we
have the power George but hang on the
line I'll get you in touch with our team
and I'll see what they can do I make no
promises but because you called and you
were brave enough to ask I mean you guys
are in Greenville so you would drive we
are yes exactly that's some gas money
already and it doesn't have to be the
VIP ticket and then there's like there's
hotels and you know so it there's a lot
of expenses involved with traveling for
an event I don't know if I would do it I
think I'd stay in my car girl no when
you do when you go to this event you
want it to be the luxury that it should
be you want to be able to enjoy it I
even tell people like hey this is for
baby step four and Beyond that's right
we're not trying to like take money from
people who are struggling and in debt we
want to see you become debt free we want
to celebrate with you at those types of
events but hang a line and uh we'll get
you in touch with our Live Events team
I'll have Christian connect you with
those folks and we'll see what we can do
for you because I'd love to meet you you
just sound awesome
that means the world well thank you so
much for the call and I appreciate the
question about sinking funds and Jay
this is a question that sinking funds
are this kind of squishy yeah thing and
people are like I don't understand talk
about it and why are they called syncing
funds and truthfully I've looked up the
etymology of a sinking fund and it's
still kind of like nah it kind of sounds
negative instead of positive we should
give it a new name
saving fund that's even less exciting
somehow we'll Workshop it off air well
let's explain to people what it is
because I think like you said it is one
of those topics that are like what's the
difference between a sinking fund and my
emergency fund so let's break that down
for the newbies yes so a sinking fund is
for a future expense that you know is
coming like a quarterly or annual bill
for example Insurance a lot of the times
mine is billed annually right and so we
have a sinking fund for our auto and
home yes so that or you know our home is
covered through escrow but the auto
insurance you want to make sure that you
got 50 bucks a month going into a
sinking fund which then sits either in
that checking or savings account you
might move it to a different account to
keep it protected so that 50 bucks a
month over 12 months adds up to 600 to
cover your auto insurance that's right
instead of it being a big surprise in
January like oh my gosh where are we
going to come up with 600 bucks to cover
the auto insurance that's right plan for
it I love that and I think to kind of to
the point of what cool was saying on the
last call sometimes I feel though George
people do a zillion sinking funds and
I'm like you might be able to just cash
flow that junk yeah I don't know that
you know it can be tempting to put five
dollars aside for this and ten dollars
aside for that and it's like wait a
second can you just like we said pay for
the oil change probably so now if you're
saving up for a big vacation coming down
the pipe you're at a baby step two
sinking fund's a great idea because a
vacation for a family of four that's
expensive that you're trying to say
about five thousand dollars yeah sinking
for not gonna magically have that money
in a random month that's right so we've
got to make a plan to get there slowly
Christmas is a great example for a
sinking fund that's right I'm looking at
my own every dollar budget going what do
I have in my sinking phone oh yeah let's
hear it you know uh membership so like
uh instacart membership something that's
a yearly expense gets charged once a
year and I always try to get the
discount because I'm Frugal come on so
if I can get an annual membership
discount by paying once a year instead
of monthly yes I'm all about that 100
that becomes an expense Amazon Prime
Spotify if you pay where do you keep
your sinking your sync King funds I keep
mine in checking and I have the amount
that I know I gotta match it up to go
hey do we make sure we have this money
in checking so that when it comes out
some people they like to move it over to
savings but you got to be diligent about
moving it back before that expense hits
I like on and this is not anything for
Ally
um Ally Bank has those buckets yes and I
like those for sinking funds so I think
buckets is maybe a better term I think
Ally did a good job with that one I'll
give them credit fun buckets
fund buckets I think we still need time
to Workshop that one but hey if you want
to check out that app I was talking
about it's called every dollar you can
download it in the App Store you can go
to everydollar.com George we've got a
killer deal over there if you want to
check it out get a free trial check out
all the premium features it will help
you make a plan for your money and give
you so much confidence I promise you
that
[Music]
thank you
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace hallow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsay show I'm George
Campbell joined by Jade warshaw the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five five two two five
so Jay this article some people have
been sending it to me has been making
waves and it's just it's borderline
hilarious but here's the headline from
nottheby.com the average American needs
to earn how much to feel financially
secure
and it goes on to say Americans feel
they would need to earn approximately
233 thousand dollars a year on average
to be secure or comfortable with their
finances from a new survey that's around
19 a month per person
I don't know if it's household it
doesn't really say but if single people
took the survey too so you know I
imagine that's in there here's the
crazier part to consider themselves rich
or possessing Financial Freedom the
average American would need to pull 483
thousand dollars according to the survey
they said that's how much I would need
what
I'm confused I'm shook really that is
wild considering uh the average earnings
full-time year-round workers in 2021 was
75 grand according to the Census Bureau
so they need uh triple that well I'm
just thinking like stat wise like the
percentage of people who earn
250 plus a year
well I think when you're is not
financially insecure you over index on
how much I need to feel very secure yeah
you know when you're frightened out of
your mind like I need a million dollars
to feel like I'm safe and that's what
this goes on to talk about it says
Americans are more than two times more
likely to feel financially insecure than
secure only one in four said they're
completely financially secure it's
probably the folks that follow the
Ramsey babies I was going to say it's
the people who have good financial
habits that's right and the rest said
uh-uh not me and a lot of people say
it's economic factors that are keeping
them from feeling financially secure of
course they're blaming the rising
interest rates and inflation and the
cost of living and the housing market
and lifestyle and it's just it never
ends but I some people were honest Jade
some said one in four blamed high or
revolving debt as the problem which at
least they're self-aware to go debt is
my problem because I think truthfully
for most people it's debt and it's
lifestyle that's right yeah yeah yes
inflation yes groceries but this idea
that the the cause everyone's shaking
their fists at the cost of eggs yeah yes
that's not the solution to your problems
is eggs being three dollars more than
they were yeah no if if it's your 700
car payment yeah if egg prices going up
is ruining your world you've got bigger
issues going on exactly facts so this
says highlighting wealth gaps and
varying costs of living many Americans
feel they need even more to pay more pay
than the national average and here's it
what's interesting women on average say
they need to earn roughly 237 K annually
or about 500 000 a year to feel rich so
more than men I wonder if that's because
women have the security gland is
stronger where they they want that
Security even more I have so many
questions yeah George this is evoking
many questions within me I don't have
the answers I'm simply a message Bearer
well I'm thinking well here's what I'm
thinking I'm going okay the more money
you have
the more margin that you should have if
you're handling it correctly and a lot
of folks that I know that have a high
incomes like this they're not spending
all of the money like it's not part of
their
they have a lot of extra that they're
like okay I can give this and I can
invest this and but it's not like oh
great now I can go see more movies and
now I can buy more steaks and now I can
does that make sense yeah like at the
end of the day you're gonna come to a
point where it's like this is my
lifestyle and I've just got to be able
to manage my my lifestyle anything on
top of that is gravy and it's cool but
it sounds like these people just want if
if you can just learn to manage your
lifestyle without a bunch of creep
without a bunch of inflated habits you
would be happy probably with the 75 000
oh which is the address once you've seen
the stats of hey people who make six
figures they're living a paycheck to
paycheck too and you go I wish I made
that kind of money I wouldn't be like
that you don't know yeah yeah a third of
people making 250 000 a year or living
paycheck to paycheck that's right and so
if you think that income is gonna just
solve all of your problems it's only
part of the equation and truthfully the
more you make the more you're gonna
spend unless you're on a proven plan
where you're living on less than you
make and you're you're investing for the
future and you're staying out of debt so
I want to encourage you guys that you
don't need to make 233 thousand dollars
to be financially secure because I meet
people that visit us that do their debt
free scream and their teachers and their
engineers and they're making 40 60 70 80
000 and their life is great oh yeah and
they can pay off their homes they can
invest for the future and the big factor
that allows them to do that is not their
income that's right it's their ability
to manage money instead of managed debt
and too many of you all are in the debt
management game instead of the money
management game and you think you're
crushing it because you're paying off
your card every month but you don't feel
like you're making track yeah you're not
making traction because you're playing
the credit card companies game that's
right you're not building your net worth
you're just helping a credit card
company sponsor their next stadium
so start playing your own game start
running your own race get out of debt
regardless of your income yes get your
income up and some people are trapped
because they're making 30 grand a year
and they need to go make more money and
get some education and step into a
different career but that's not the
solution to your problems yeah
absolutely I know plenty of people who
make the like mid-range six figures and
it ain't all it's cracked up to be for
them because they have not learned the
principles that we teach on the show
every day and so you know unfortunately
the more your lifestyle goes up a lot of
people it that lifestyle creep is so
real we need to do a segment on how to
know when to you know when there's a
tease yeah how can you know when to
Lifestyle like upgrade your lifestyle
without it being the negative lifestyle
creep that keeps people from yes because
we get a bad rap for me like they don't
want us to spend money no we want you to
spend money yeah that you haven't
budgeted for without sacrificing your
future that's it well there's the
segment right there George you just
explained it all right let's go to the
phones Walker is in Austin gosh I want
to make so many jokes about Walker Texas
Rangers and I will not Walker because
you get that so much don't you
I do get that yeah I'm gonna avoid it I
just teased it but I'm not doing it how
can we help today
I appreciate it I had a question for you
me and my fiance are about 35 days away
from getting married we're super excited
thank you yeah but we are going to
combine finances once we're after the
honeymoon once you get back from after
the honeymoon smart but I think me
personally I want to push for not going
to baby step four and just going three
being investing but my work offers such
a good match it's a six percent Roth
401k and I don't know if I'm missing out
if I just go 3B for a year and a half or
two years to try to get a good down
payment for the house and I'm trying to
figure out how to budget that because I
only have an excess of about 700 a month
okay so you have 700 bucks a month uh
after expenses and the wedding's gonna
be paid for you're out of debt you
already have an emergency fund
yes sir and luckily we're both Financial
Peace babies her parents coordinating
classes and my parents lived out a few
and so we're in really good Financial
stats we have uh we're all ready to be
at baby step four once we're so so good
okay no it's exciting I love it so 3B
for those listening is saving up for a
house down payment so you get out of
debt you get the emergency fund in place
then we're gonna save up for the house
down payment and that's kind of this in
between investing and honestly it's a
squishy baby step because it's a Choose
Your Own Adventure yeah some people
choose to invest all 15 while saving up
the down payment some people do zero
some people just do the match some
people do something else so there's no
right or wrong way to do this it's based
on your goals your age your urgency to
get a house your urgency to build wealth
and for your situation you know could
you get that match and then do the six
percent investing and the rest go to the
down payment how much slower would that
cause your down payment process
um I don't know exactly if I just took
the match I was using the the free
mortgage calculator you all have on
ramsaysolutions.com love it and I was
using that and it looked like I would
need a pretty substantial
down payment in order to meet that 25 of
your take-home pay going towards your
mortgage rate Yeah Austin is a hot
Market please
yeah it's it's rough out here and so and
we're both young and she's gonna be in
her internship so she's not gonna be
making money for a while so be living
off of my income but to answer your
question I think it would extended by
about a year so about three years in if
I just did the six percent to kind of
flex that muscle of investing okay if
I'm in your shoes I mean marriage is a
lot to begin with I'm gonna just rent
for a while and if it extends it by a
year and we gotta wait another year yeah
I'm okay with that because I think
that's gonna pay dividends on the other
side when you're 16 you're going wow
yeah do the do the math on the
investment calculator and go what is
that six percent turn into with your age
30 years from now that might make you
gain some patience on that side but
either way you're gonna be okay you're
going to be multi-millionaires at this
point even if you invest zero percent
right now so I'm not that concerned but
man it's hard to pass up that match when
you guys have done this the right way so
well thanks for the call man this is the
Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George camel
joined by Jade warshaw this hour
this is a show about you America about
your life and your money helping you win
are you seeing a theme Here you you are
the secret sauce you're you're the main
event you're the main character we want
to give you that main character energy
if you feel like life has just been
happening to you we want it to happen
for you and you are a huge part of that
process and we want to see you in so
give us a call at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Tiffany is up
next in Denver Tiffany welcome to the
show
yeah I enjoyed George and Jade thank you
for taking my calls so we are on baby
steps seven no wonder you sound so
chipper
thank you um we are essentially
wondering how much we can spend on
vacations or how we can determine how
much we can this is such a fun question
what a terrible great problem to have
you do what you want to do okay so tell
us a little bit more what kind of
vacation are you wanting
well um we have five weeks of vacation a
year where dual income no kids early 40s
and white we save a lot
um and invest a lot try to be generous
givers also but the more we go on the
more we just liked vacation we really
liked to cruise wouldn't mind honestly
doing several a year so we also want to
save a lot for the for retirement I mean
we'd rather sacrifice now to have more
later and that's where we're really
struggling with how much can we spend
now I think as long as you're
doing the things that you need to do
right like let's just say you've already
set aside a certain amount that you're
wanting to give whether it's a
percentage or a certain ratio and maybe
you've set aside a certain ratio for
other things like you said re continuing
on with retirement as long as you're not
touching those things it's kind of like
that same Principle as before as long as
you're doing the things that you need to
do you have the margin to do the things
that you want to do and
I mean my guess is that how much do you
guys earn
I think about combining 264 and what
would be like an outrageous vacation
would it would blow your mind if you
spent that much on a vacation
we did last year we spent 13 on one
um but we I mean we have five weeks and
so we want to go on more than 13 a year
so even if you did a few of those a year
that's still not touching your world and
you're investing in your bills and
you're giving and so I feel like it's
more it's there's no specific ratio
where I'm like don't ever spend more
than three percent of your total right
we don't have a ratio like that
especially in baby step seven where you
really do have so much more options and
I think as long as you guys are in
agreement and nothing is out of control
and you're never going into debt there's
no amount that I would say hey yeah if
you're going to spend a hundred thousand
dollars I would be like okay let's
I'm gonna barf just thinking about that
but spending 13 Grand when you make 260
and you're totally debt free with no
house payment I mean your next goal you
want to be able to enjoy it when you're
in your 40s you know not just when
you're in one day when we're in our 60s
we'll do a 13 000 big you want to be do
this stuff now while you've got the
energy what do you have in retirement so
far
um I see I think between the two of us
Investments and our 401k and tsp maybe
about
2 million total wow look I'm going back
on what George said if y'all saved up
for a really long time and had a hundred
thousand dollars on a vacation I am not
even mad it really would not be that big
a big part of your world you know like
Dave if Dave Ramsey would here would be
like that's like you know me buying them
that's a biscuit yeah he loves the
biscuits and so I think you dream it up
budget for it and do it pay cash baby
that's so cool
this is this is why you guys did this
stuff right it's so that you had options
in margin and you can do this kind of
stuff you can do this outrageous stuff
including giving including spending
including investing I mean I don't know
many people that are in their 40s with
two million dollars and no debt that
doesn't even include your house I mean
by the time you guys actually retire
it's gonna be popping off you guys are
doing so so well I'm so proud Tiffany
should be behind this desk teaching us
all how to get it I know right you are
incredible so so proud of you guys send
me some photos from vacation because
we're behind this desk you know we we're
not out there I want to go take us with
you 100 000 vacation I can't even
imagine what I would spend a hundred
thousand dollars George I mean that's
like multiple over water Bungalows like
for my entire Fame yeah well you gotta
you gotta if you're taking a leave of
absence so you gotta part of that is
probably like
to account for income you know like pay
loss so you've got to think about that I
have five weeks they got plenty of time
to take off yeah that's true they're
doing the PT but I'm just saying I don't
know if you can spin that in five weeks
I feel like you need an extended for me
to do that
let me let me play Dave Ramsey could do
it because he's on a vacation right now
and I'm like Dave once encouraged me to
buy a 500 bottle of wine and I it blew
my mind so I know Dave could do it okay
I'm too Frugal for that I'm like I can't
I'm not a someone here I can't tell the
difference he was like if you
oh let's let me see what you think he
was like if you make 200 and I think the
person made 250 000 he was like you buy
a buy a 500 bottle of wine and I just I
had to clutch
I'm too Middle Eastern for that I'm like
I'm my parents are immigrants we can't
be out here he's right but I was like oh
okay I will accept Dave generosity if he
wants to do that for me yes thank you
Dave well he wasn't the one buying it he
was telling other folks yeah so if
someone else buys it I'm like good for
you you deserve it good for you treat
yourself I don't know if I could do it
no I'm not there yet I'm not there all
right Ashley's up next in Cleveland
Ashley welcome to the show
hi thank you for taking the call sure
what's going on
so we've been working the program and we
are at the point where we're ready to
invest our 15 well we're still working
on our emergency fund but shortly we'll
be investing our 15 percent
but our situation is a little unique so
I'm wondering if you might advise me to
pay down our mortgage first
okay and all you need this is that my
husband
um is disabled from the military so they
gave him a retirement package at the age
of 35. and we will receive non-tax
income from him for the rest of his life
including
um
um insurance benefits and things
so
we also have an insurance plan that if
something was to happen to him I
continue to receive those benefits for
the rest of my life I'm also working I'm
a teacher
so because we are
set up for retirement already I'm
wondering if it is a benefit to just pay
down our mortgage quicker and then
invest the 15 or maybe even more at that
point
so what is this retirement package look
like
a pretty all-inclusive program are
medical bills are very low if any and
that's that income is not taxable
okay so we're basically four thousand
take-home pay forever and that's your
retirement plan right now
yeah and that
is the way I think talking about this is
George is similar to the way we might
treat like a pension or something like
that right whereas we we say to invest
15 but if you have something like a
pension you're not counting that as the
whole amount right you're you're saying
oh if my pension gives me seven percent
okay yeah but we we can't control it so
let's count it as three and a half
percent that sort of thing so I'm kind
of wondering if you might look at this
and say okay instead of investing 15
have this account for whatever that
percentage is let's say it accounts for
three percent of that you know that sort
of thing and and run it back like that
I'm just wondering I I haven't met
anyone that's like man we put 15 away
and we just ended up having too much
money in retirement yeah blue and so I'm
kind of in the boat of like what would
it look like if you still invested 15
and then aggressively paid off the house
using some of this income how how much
longer do you guys have on this mortgage
if you did that
it's a due mortgage so we still have
14 in a couple months 14 years in a
couple months okay and you what do you
say what kind of mortgage
I said it's a new mortgage oh a new
mortgage oh so you just started okay got
it well I would see how much we can
allocate do some math and go hey if I
invested 15 of our household income and
then the rest went towards the mortgage
how quickly could we pay it off and my
guess is you're going to look up and say
oh we could do this in like seven years
yeah and it's no big deal you guys have
time so I just you know I don't want to
rely on I don't know what life's going
to look like in retirement and so I
don't know that four grand a month is
going to be enough what if you guys want
to do something outrageous and give more
and spend more and go on a 13 000
vacation and that's why I say I would
invest to be on the safe side and be on
that side of history but either way you
guys are doing great thanks so much for
the call this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show our
scripture of the day comes from Proverbs
6 verses 6 through 8. go to the ant you
sluggard consider its ways and be wise
it has no Commander no overseer or ruler
yet it stores its Provisions in summer
and gathers its food at Harvest
that'll preach Thomas Edison once said
opportunity is missed by most people
because it is dressed in overalls and
looks like work come on ain't that the
truth so the question you need to ask is
are are you smarter than an aunt I would
like to think so but I mean America's
broken these ants are at least they're
like hey we gotta eat this winter oh
like they're storing up you know what I
mean so it's a good question to ask
tonight at dinner yeah that's a fun
dinner conversation just don't get in a
fight with your spouse
all right let's go to the phones Matt
joins us up next in Detroit Matt welcome
to the show
hi uh my name is Matt from Detroit I was
curious if um paying off our current
home right now is the best solution for
us or in being in the market and looking
to purchase and upgrade a new home
okay so tell us more are you already
planning to upgrade where is the house
move coming from yes so our house is
getting smaller my wife just gave one
gave birth to twins about a year ago so
it's starting to move around Edge
how big is it
it's 1300 square feet there's no open
concept there's just like one living
room that was good for just using even
when the babies weren't really moving
now they're moving around and we're just
realizing we need a bigger space and but
we're not at the point to where it's a
must yet however we are deadly in the
market
um are you guys debt free other than the
mortgage
you know we have a mortgage that runs us
about 1100 a month and I have a 500 a
month car payment other than that or
debt free and like the note is left at
like 17 grand
how quickly could you get that car paid
off
I could do it tomorrow if I wanted to
you got the money
yes we have a decent amount of money
saved how much and um about between the
both of us we have around
260 270 thousand dollars goodness
gracious that's great where did that
come from just steadily over time
yeah just a lot of savings and I paid
off a lot of student loans in the very
beginning and my wife and I are both
working she's working only three days a
week so after she gave birth she was she
was working four days a week but after
she gave birth she went to three days to
you know so she could spend more times
with the kids okay what do you both do
if you're living
she's a dentist and I'm in I.T with a
4500 around here wow so great income I'm
guessing what's your income
uh together combined I'd say it varies
depending on a bonus but I'd say safe
bet around 250 260 a year good job and
what's left on the mortgage
120 I think 120 000. and what's the
house worth
right now it's looking around like
two I would say I could probably get 224
easily
okay so after fees let's call it you
know a little under 100 you might walk
away with if you sold it today
yeah that's what that's what I was
thinking and maybe I would um you know
put it for sale by owner to get rid of
the real estate cost but that might just
yeah I definitely use a pro
you would yes 100 they're gonna Market
it and ever it's going to be so dialed
in that you will make more and it will
cover the fees that's how I've seen it
that's like somebody walking up to your
job and being like uh I could probably
do it myself you'd be like no you can't
no but either way Matt here's the thing
I'm looking at the numbers and either if
you pay down the mortgage you just have
that Equity built in when you go to sell
and you roll it into the the new house
so I don't see it as an either or I like
actually putting it onto the mortgage
because it's a four savings plan and it
stops me from doing other things with it
yeah
um like I'm gonna upgrade the car I'm
gonna get a renovation so I like you
paying down this Mortgage in the
meantime and honestly you got 260. why
not pay off the car and the house
tomorrow I agree man wouldn't that be a
feeling yeah I was watching some of your
things and that's what made or some of
your videos on YouTube and that's what
made me call in because we're looking at
a home we're looking to upgrade it
honestly we're looking to build yeah so
I'm thinking that that's going to cost
us we're in the market for around I
don't know it was 600 000 range for us
but I didn't know if if this is too
premature I was thinking we pay
everything off wait a couple years build
back you know have come come into the
market with I guess more liquid cash you
definitely could do that I mean like
George said before this is really more
about your timeline I like the idea of
getting free from the debt including the
mortgage they then it kind of opens up
your priorities to see you might get
into that debt-free lifestyle and feel
like you know what this feels so good
like I know we've got the twins in the
house but we've got so many options now
and you might decide to wait it out and
save up more or you know again just
because you have the paid off mortgage
you're still building Equity so it's not
like you're there's nothing lost there's
only something gained you know
so if I'm in your shoes Matt I'm paying
all this off tomorrow 17K car loan gone
120 000 mortgage gone that still would
leave you based on the savings you
talked about still leave you with 120.
right and liquid cash yes absolutely it
would and that's just getting rid of
that much money is kind of I it would
hurt so great because you worked hard to
do it and you love seeing that balance
but it's kind of a false illusion
because you owe 120 Grand on the other
side and 17 grand in car payment with
interest and interest and so I would be
I'd want to get completely debt free
stop paying lenders interest because you
are too smart for that and you make too
much money to be doing that and then you
have 120 now we can start making a plan
all right how much down payment do we
want to put down what kind of house
would that get us what if we could do it
with cash now you have some options
yeah that's that's kind of what I was
thinking as well and it just feels good
to hear that from someone else and
yeah that's kind of yeah that's the boat
we're in um I was I was also thinking
well we could sell the house right now I
would take you know maybe 80k equity and
you know build a pool or whatever when
we throw down a 20 down payment but I'm
looking at the mortgage and we're
talking that's going to be you know
maybe five thousand dollars with
utilities like all in almost you guys
make 260. and so I would be looking at
these numbers going all right we're
gonna do a 15-year fix no matter what we
want the payment to be a quarter of our
take-home pay that will start to dictate
what kind of budget for the home you get
I want you obviously to put down 20 or
more with your income and your situation
and you'll be able to do that but don't
get too crazy on the other side and go
get a million dollar home and go well
we'll figure it out make a plan do the
math pay off all your debt and it's
going to feel so good when you get there
man thanks for the call such a great
Point George I feel like
um in his situation it's a great
situation but it can also be precarious
because there's a lot of money lying
around here there's a great income here
it can be very easy to not be as
detailed as you need to be end up with
too much house because it's like oh we
got money we got it we can kind of out
earn we can out earn some of this no
it's the same that same equation Works
no matter if you're making 60 000 or 260
000 uh when it comes to this next home
purchase and making sure that it falls
within those guidelines yeah a lot of
diligence there all right let's try to
take a real quick one John in Knoxville
get right to the question John we're up
against the clock
hey guys so I'll be quick I'm a medical
student
um and my wife she works a pretty normal
job we want to set up ourselves well for
investing we're 24 and 23. I wanted some
advice from you guys how we can maybe
invest to pay off some med school debt
and also I just set ourselves up well
for life cool so you're both in school
uh yeah I'm a med student she's about to
start her Masters okay so what's the
current income
current income households altogether
will probably be about sixty thousand
and that's today
no that starts in about a month okay so
one month from now we're making 60 how
much debt do you guys have
uh right now I've got a current about 20
000 uh in education and we've got 15 000
on a car
how how are you guys paying for
education
um well when it comes back
um we actually don't have to pay on it
yet but we have to start paying on it in
like a month or two and so in that
starts we're just going to pay you know
you're taking loans for actively taking
loans for education
that's right yeah for my medical
education so you still have more loans
to take out at this point
that's right oof well you're not going
to like our answer but you're not going
to invest your way out of debt I
wouldn't invest until you guys clean up
this meth and I would try to mess and I
would try to cash flow the rest of it
and avoid more bleeding AKA more debt
yeah because at the rate that you're
borrowing what do you project will be
the final amount of debt when you
graduate
when I graduated I think we'll be at
360. oh no sir don't do it John
John don't do it bud
dude this is gonna only hold you guys
back and I would not invest a dime right
now because you gotta act like you're
broke because you guys are broke and I
would try to cash flow as much of this
as possible I would not take on any more
debt if you need to pause these career
dreams for a while but dude walking away
with 360 in debt is going to be a
nightmare find a program that'll pay you
to go to school I know they're out there
get creative but I would not continue
down this path my friend that puts this
hour of the Ramsey Show in the books
until next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
[Music]
thank you
hey it's George camel if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsaysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]